exhausted french medical staff like last
christmas this intensive care unit in
marseille is struggling with the
pressure the most seriously ill are
patients who haven't been vaccinated
like david saber
his wife esther says she thought she was
going to be a widow a few days ago
david's grateful he's still alive
he says if he'd been vaccinated he
wouldn't have been at this level of
intensive care
while omicron infections seem to have a
lower rate of hospitalization the
extreme increases in infection rates
mean the sheer volume of cases are
quickly putting medics under pressure
while france is breaking records so too
is italy
the uk has been running christmas day
clinics to give vaccinations the
priority is on booster jabs the
government's heavy reliance on
vaccinations to try and quell the
omicron infection rates is in question
on christmas eve a record daily figure
of a hundred and twenty thousand was
reached and now the office of national
statistics is warning that one in ten
people in london may be infected with
covid in the coming days
last christmas queen elizabeth assured
people suffering in britain they
wouldn't be alone
this year though her focus wasn't on
curvid it was the death of her husband
prince philip the duke of edinburgh she
expressed her grief on a personal level
talking of how she missed the man to
whom she'd been married for 73 years
christmas can be hard for those who have
lost loved ones
this year especially i understand why
but for me in the months since the death
of my beloved philip
i have drawn great comfort from the
warmth and affection of the many
tributes to his life and work
at 95 years of age the queen takes
immense care to avoid any exposure to
the virus but for so many people
especially in london that isn't the case
and the health service is now warning
there's been a 40 increase in hospital
admissions
this christmas is surreal for so many
people living in the british capital
the government says that it's watching
the data before making any decisions on
heavier restrictions
that prediction of one in ten people
here suffering from covid is a sobering
statistic
the government may well introduce
heavier restrictions possibly before the
new year
andrew simmons al jazeera london